A  OPINION THAT RECEDENTEEKTER K
WIR SUE WAWH
COMES NEXTS DISCUSS NON LEGAL
ANALYST PREET BHARARA E VENGD E
>> THIS EK
ACCUSATIONS OF FUD, CID TIRETO
IS HAPNG
NOW.
AND A COUNTRY THAT
THE
WHAT IS GOING ON HERE?
GIVES
IT'S OBVIOUSL RTUAING TOLD
IS ABOUT TE OTHER D THING IS IT
THE CHIE
INAL. ALSO THATEDIDT IN THE LAS
DAY OR TWO.
ALTHOUGH WN'T KNOW T
ICE SAM AL--ST INK
EVEN TODAY PEOPL
ED TACCEPT
'S G
STS ITS IF RE DETACHED FROM HISY
SPEAKING IN
BUT WH HAVE AN OK IS T IN
, BECAUSS  IN SOME
FA SOMWAR THE
OR THE ARGUMENTS
PES EVHAT ARE UNUSL AN
IN IN  AAM WITH THE AND UTP THE
THEN OF02 LERNS HAS H
D A SYS' WAS IN
COMMUNICATION WITH PE WITH
RESPECT TO JAN
BE OBI I THINKOUAS OTHE IS GOINT
TRUAITH
RESPECT PEOPLE HAVR THE  A SLIDE
I  WAS ABOUTNOT AN GETTING WORS
THE OTHER THING OU THOMAS IS TAN
S THE DOOR FOR OTHER BAD
OMS AND
DISCUSSING A FEW MINUTES AGO,
REASONING I TO
E PEOPLE
HAVING A DAT
INICBU
OPINE WITHDRAWAL
AND Y OF OTHER
EASY THING TO SAYA SPEECH PEOPD
T S IN
GONE THI PARTICULARLY WHEN
TAL
CLCED EXWHERE HE IS. SPEAKAT JL
CONFERENCE IRETRIAL,GONT
INUTHOULD BE, QUOTE --LDED
D ERSE
CAN'T
SOCIETY LE.
SO, I MEME COURT
INIED?
ACS PART. TH
-
IN THE CONSTITUTSPANON THEENEN
KNNG ABOUTTHHE OTHRKS.
IRS  OF
ONS ABOUE THOMAS
STATEMCEPTIN
OTLIED K OF THE CONATIVE
REACTION, THTIREACTION HAS BEEN
WEING, TOLERANT OF BT GURING WA
THROUG S CHEATING MERR
ME BSHBARRETT TO A SEAT ON THE A
AWAY?
WERE THEY ACCEPTING THE OUTCOME
ROE V. DEIT'S THE HEIGHT  IRONE
NN JOABISKUPI FERING STARKBERTSS
APPEARS SU INEFFECTUAL
OFIO ADI CE DOO GET CKOU
C
THE OB I, ON'TCH IN CONTROL HE O
DIVIDED.
THT RESPECT THEM AS MUCH AS
EY.
AND IF YOU'RE  MOR
THINKOU
HAVEUSH
SSFUL MEMBER OF TH
COT  THE CHI
ON
EVGOTH
WAY FROM TIME TO TIME OR WANTSLE
OPINOR REACTION FROM